so today i'm talking with tom and tom
has a channel called wayla tom did i say
it correct that's it okay absolutely so
maybe tom you could briefly introduce
yourself and how you got into what
you're doing and in fact explain what
you are doing yeah absolutely well first
of all thank you for having me on your
channel i've been a big fan for a long
time and uh so basically uh i started
learning italian somewhere around 15
years ago
and um i never really thought that i had
a passion for languages till i actually
got into it and i saw just how cool it
was to be able to understand the
language of my family because i have an
italian background so i was always
around the language growing up and so
then when i got to university i wanted
to take italian classes and i remember
sitting with my advisor i had taken my
proficiency exam like everyone does
and she said look you placed out of our
classes would you like to teach i said
teach
i said at one point i was happy because
she said yeah you could get paid by the
school you could do this but i was like
i still want to take classes she goes
well i'm sorry unfortunately you can't
do that so i got into teaching at the
same time i was running my youtube
channel just as a fun passion project to
share what i knew with other people
and uh and then yeah now so many years
down the line i'm teaching italian i
teach english i became a tefl i got my
tefl certificate and and now i'm
learning french i even shared some
content and french on my channel so just
been enjoying the ride
tell me you saw the the uh you went to
university in new york or wherever yes
in new york yeah in new york
which university if i'm asked
yeah it's called hofstra university okay
so they had italian an italian program
at the university
they did yeah but i was a business major
right so i was kind of there for
business right but i thought it would be
fun just to take a few classes
everybody's italian it's still
interesting that they had an italian
program do they still have the italian
program yeah they still do okay very
good and how many
foreign languages do they teach
or do you know i think they i don't know
exactly how many but i know for certain
we had arabic i know we had french
italian spanish
uh i don't know what other languages we
have but i know for certain those ones
yeah
and
the program was it
what they now refer to as heritage
language learners people with an italian
background that were taking italian or
people who had no particular connection
to italian yeah it was it was all
different kinds of people and i really
got to see that through the tutoring
because i was tutoring both
undergraduate and graduate students
and so it was people of all different
ages all different backgrounds and it
really gave me an appreciation for how
much italian i learned thanks to my
family because there were certain
expressions that were challenging for
students that i never had to formally
learn i just understood
uh so yeah okay and so
um
this how well did they learn like did
they what was the focus of the teaching
was it getting them to speak the
language language was it having them
access you know the works of literature
of italian or what what was the program
yeah it was definitely heavy there was a
small section on grammar and there was
definitely a big emphasis on italian
culture italian films italian history
italian poetry as well like everyone
learns about dante and um so that was
also particularly enriching for me um so
yeah big emphasis on the culture so do
people read for example italian novels
yes they read novels they'll dissect the
language for example in italian i'm sure
you're familiar in literature they use
the
remote
which in everyday spoken italian it's
not really used but what we're saying
what were some of the authors that were
that were studied
i can't remember all of them but i know
for certain dante but usually they would
also take like news articles as well and
they would talk about current events and
then learn the culture that way right
but so they were reading in italian
they were reading in italian yes okay
yes no i did i uh
when i was working on my italian i read
promesi sposi which um oh sure sure when
i say that to italians i say holy cow
like we hated doing that in school
but i thought it was phenom phenomenal
because it's sort of very exotic it's
the you know it was written in the 19th
century about the 17th century and or
whatever 16th i don't know and it was
great and i had an audio book for it
but i i've read alberto moravia and also
had an audiobook for it like i like to
listen
to an audiobook where i also have the
ebook and then i import the ebook into
link and then i look up all the words
and phrases but i did a lot of listening
to uh italian audiobooks
were audiobooks used in the program
uh no i don't recall any audio books
being used but they would have for
homework they would have to listen to a
mock conversation and then they would
have to like give the answers or write a
small paragraph explaining what it was
about all right okay yeah we should get
one link i think so i think that'd be a
great idea get that authentic input
now the people who studied italian what
were their motivations their students so
so you know a lot of people here in new
york do have italian heritage so there's
definitely a piece of people that when
they sign up for an italian class they
say you know this is a way for me to
connect with my roots with my
grandparents my great grandparents and
then there are other people that just
genuinely they love the culture they
love the food they love visiting italy
and so um i really have yet to meet
someone that dislikes italy so it's
really a wonderful wonderful thing it's
a yeah yeah it's a good product to be
selling for sure it is it is actually
yes so a lot of people then have in mind
that they would like to go to italy at
some point in fact do many of them take
like a third year and go abroad and
study an italian
university or something
exactly so many people do it it almost
feels like a rite of passage for so many
people just to go and study abroad in
florence it's like the thing to do
yeah
there was a foreign languages university
in this lovely medieval town i can't
remember what the name of it was but at
any rate it doesn't matter where you're
going italy it's it's a lot of right
absolutely and so you said you were
teaching people of all ages so that the
students there weren't necessarily
people in their you know early 20s or
late teens you also had some mature
students
exactly many mature students and then
even as i tutor outside of school um you
know on my own with my own business i've
had i've taught people i think from as
young as 12 to as old as about 83
and it's so beautiful to see
uh what it's like to teach people of all
different ages and all different
backgrounds and and it does give you as
a teacher a lot of insight into
what you need to do for people of
different ages because younger people
tend to be more used to the school you
know they're fresh out of school or
currently in it so they like that more
traditional approach whereas you're more
mature students they've been out in the
workforce for x amount of years they
have families they've traveled to italy
so uh it's interesting to as a teacher
to
hone in on those different skills and
those different different strengths and
weaknesses how would you
sort of what sorts of things do you do
maybe you could explain a little bit
about
your website and yeah our link youtube
channel whatever it is and then your
teaching
activity and how people can find you
and so forth
yeah absolutely so uh i'm on many
different social media platforms but
primarily i do use um instagram and
youtube are my big ones and so what i
have on my youtube channel is videos to
learn italian in a fun and casual way
but i do have a focus on grammar as well
because i believe grammar can also be
fun and then i do the same for english
but it's teaching english to italian
speakers so uh and what i do which is
not
always the the hottest thing to do in
the teaching uh world is i do teach in
the native language so i will teach
so i don't do it in full immersion style
if a student wants it then i do it but
on my youtube channel i teach italian in
english and teach english in italian
uh and then i also have some french
videos because i wanted to share my
notes and i teach french in english but
anyway so my youtube channel is short
videos fun and casual i try to focus on
authentic language not only textbook
language and then what i do outside of
youtube where i privately teach people
is that is completely tailored to
whatever the student wants
if the student wants the traditional
let's look at a digital whiteboard let's
go through a whole verb tense and
exercises we do it if they want to just
talk for an hour or 30 minutes in
italian we do that too so um i found
that it's really useful to have someone
that you can go to and just ask whatever
you want right whether the question is
super advanced about the subjunctive
mood or whether it's you know what tom i
never knew what que vodira means they
always taught me because i see nifika in
school and i love doing that kind of
stuff
i mean it is true that um
there are certain things that we just
don't notice in the language
and certain things that we get very
curious about so um so yeah and i think
it's also very important to cater it to
the individual needs of the learner
there are some teachers who say this is
my method and today we're going to do
this
right you can't do that people you got
to maintain that motivation absolutely
absolutely well that's very interesting
and
we will put links to your various uh
presences uh in the description box and
uh maybe in fact hopefully some people
want to go there and take advantage
and yeah thank you for taking the time
thank you steve much appreciated okay
bye-bye all right chad
[Music]
you